I was a guest on your show and I
actually went on you were one of my
favorite guests oh good really I meant
on kind of early I know you've had a lot
of guests since then do you feel like
you how do you find out the you know you
I I am I got a I'm not Tooting my own
horn now but I am a really good
interviewer why because I listen that's
why I'm a listener and pay attention I
listen and then I and then I formulate a
question and come and I had one note
which I did notice which is that you do
jump in a lot instead of like just
letting the person answer the question
I beg to differ with you but I think
that I'm I'm a person who I grew there's
four siblings in my household and two
parents and we we learn to listen and
that's what we do I'm just saying as a
friend and it's someone who does this a
lot I just thought that was one little
note I could how often do you do this
it's not a one-night thing
I do it enough let's just say all right
you're saying you don't interrupt I
don't believe I do I hate a little
montage of my appearance on Kevin Nealon
show hiking with Kevin let's take a look
anxiety runs in my family
yes you are anxious I remember that now
and you do that little finger thing yeah
I would cry in my fingers together and
just I wear a finger guard at night you
know if you're gonna make jokes when
we're bringing on the real therapist
then maybe give you a terrible therapist
and when I was at SNL that's where I
know you from yeah you were right
artists in Casey almost a breakthrough
and I hated the way I looked I hated
having still I
how do you do it why do you do it you
were a writer on The Simpsons yes how
was that well great a lot of funny guys
wrote on the show and girls yeah
yes question you got a but the person
answer metal thing what do you like the
most about being a talk show host I like
that I stick with the question I asked
and don't move on to another one
cuz that's right away
I thought that was I thought that was a
perfect yeah that was a perfect
interview perfect and it really was my
favorite thing is you swung by my house
I came out and I forgot like oh people
put makeup on I put on white sunblock so
I look even whiter in that and then I
grabbed a hat off the shelf that I never
wear and put it on and I looked at this
later
it's the it's ridiculous crazy person
really I felt like I was with a crazy
person yeah I really did but I've gotten
a lot better at interviews now and
listening in things I'll give an example
Kona what what a3 when you learn how to
swim it probably was about I don't know
nine eight
are you done are you finished
yes I'm done yes are you a morning
person yeah I like to get up in the
morning and I like to to ride my bike I
really like bike riding done okay it's
not a cool I'll be rude I'm not a good
wine let me
hey weeds is coming back people are very
excited about that and you'll be part of
it I'm hoping yeah have you seen the
show yeah I watched it back in the day
but it's my character's name I don't
remember his name I always whatever
you're anything I just think it's Kevin
doing some kind of well I know your
character name on this show I don't know
this guy though yeah okay that's Randy
Randall I love Randy they do have Randy
you can see new episodes and they're
getting better all the time of hiking
with Kevin better equipment - it's not
as shaky as the one back in yours
every the other thing I liked about that
what every Thursday and YouTube to wear
that hat every time